can you taste words it was a question
that caught me by surprise the summer I
was giving a talk at a literary festival
and afterwards as I was signing books
a teenage girl came with her friend and
this is what she asked me I told her
that some people experienced an overlap
in their senses so that they could hear
colors or see sounds and mini writers
were fascinated by this subject myself
included but she cut me off and a bit
impatiently and said yeah I know love
that is called synesthesia we learned at
our school but my mom is reading your
book and she says there's lots of food
and ingredients and the long dinner
scene in it she gets hungry at every
page so I was thinking how come you
don't get hungry when you write and I
thought maybe maybe you could taste
words does it make sense and actually it
did make sense because ever since my
childhood each letter in the alphabet
has a different color and colors bring
me flavors so Frances the color purple
is quite pungent almost perfumed and any
words that I associate with purple taste
the same way such as sunset is a very
spicy word but I was worried that if I
tell all of this to the teenager it
might sound either to obstruct or
perhaps to weird and there wasn't enough
time anyhow because people were waiting
in the queue so it suddenly felt like
what I was trying to convey was more
complicated and detailed than what the
circumstances allowed me to say and and
I did what I usually do in similar
situations I stammered I shut down and I
I stopped talking I stopped talking
because the truth was complicated even
though I knew deep within that one
should never
ever remain silent for fear of
complexity so I want to start my talk
today with the answer that I was not
able to give on that day yes I can't
taste words sometimes that is not always
and happy words have a different flavor
than sad words I like to explore how
does the word creativity taste like or
equality love revolution and what about
motherland these days it's particularly
this last words that troubles me it
leaves a sweet taste on my tongue like
cinnamon a bit a bit of rosewater and
golden apples but underneath underneath
there's a sharp tongue like nettles and
dandelion the taste of my motherland
Turkey is a mixture of sweet and bitter
and the reason why I'm telling you this
is because I think there's more and more
people all around the world today who
have similarly mixed emotions about the
lands they come from
we love our native countries yeah how
can we not we feel attached to the
people the culture the lands the food
and here at the same time we feel
increasingly frustrated by its politics
and politicians sometimes to the point
of despair or hurt or anger I want to
talk about emotions and the need to
boost our emotional intelligence I think
it's a pity that mainstream political
theory pays very little attention to
emotions oftentimes analysts and experts
are so busy with data and metrics that
they seem to forget those things in life
that are difficult to measure and
perhaps impossible to cluster under
statistical models but I think this is a
mistake for two main reasons
firstly because we are emotional beings
as human beings I think we all are like
that but secondly and this is new we
have entered a new stage in world
history
in which collective sentiments guides
and misguide politics more than ever
before and through social media and
social networking these sentiments are
further amplified polarized and they
travel around the world quite fast ours
is the age of anxiety anger distrust
resentment and I think lots of fear but
here's the thing even though there's
plenty of research about economic
factors there's relatively few studies
about emotional factors why is it that
we underestimate feelings and
perceptions I think it's going to be one
of our biggest intellectual challenges
because our political systems are
replete with emotions and country after
country we have seen illiberal
politicians
exploiting these emotions and yet within
the academia and among the
intelligentsia we're yet to take
emotions seriously I think we should and
just like we should focus on economic
inequality worldwide we need to pay more
attention to emotional and cognitive
gaps worldwide and how to bridge these
gaps because they do they do matter
years ago when I was still living in
Istanbul an American scholar working on
women writers in the Middle East came to
see me and at some point in our exchange
she said I understand why you're a
feminist because you know you you live
in Turkey and I said to her I don't
understand why you're not a feminist
because you know you live in America
[Applause]
and and she loves she took it as a joke
and and the moment passed but but the
way she had divided the world into two
imaginary camps in two opposite camps it
bothered me and it stayed with me
according to this imaginary map some
parts of the world were liquids
countries there were like choppy waters
not yet settled some other parts of the
world namely the West were solid safe
and stable so it was the liquid lands
that needed feminism and activism and
human rights and those of us who were
unfortunate enough to come from such
places had to keep struggling for these
most essential values but there was hope
since history moved forward even the
most unsteady lands would someday catch
up and meanwhile the citizens of solid
lands could take comfort in the progress
of history and in the triumph of the
liberal order they could support the
struggles of other people elsewhere but
they themselves did not have to struggle
for the basics of democracy anymore
because they were beyond that stage I
think in the year 2016 this hierarchical
geography was shattered to pieces our
world no longer follows this dualistic
pattern in the scholars mind if it ever
did yeah now we know that history does
not necessarily move forward sometimes
it rose circles even slides backwards
and that generations can make the same
mistakes that their great-grandfather's
had made and now we know that there is
no such thing as solid countries versus
liquid countries in fact we are all
living in liquid times just like the
late zygmunt bauman
told us and Bauman has another
definition for our age he used to say we
are all going to be walking or
moving moving sands and if that's the
case I think it should concern us women
more than men because when societies
slide backwards into authoritarianism
nationalism or religious fanaticism
women have much more to lose that is why
this needs to be a vital moment not only
for global activism but in my opinion
for global sisterhood as well
[Music]
but I want to make a little confession
before I go any further until recently
whenever I took part in an international
conference or festival I would be
usually one of the more depressed
speakers having seen how our dreams of
democracy and how our dreams of
coexistence were crushed in Turkey both
you know gradually but also with a
bewildering speed over the years I felt
quite demoralized and at these festivals
there would be some other gloomy writers
and they would come from places such as
Egypt Nigeria Pakistan Bangladesh
Philippines China Venezuela Russia and
we would smile at each other in sympathy
this camaraderie of the dunes and you
could call us would which worried and
depressed writers International Club but
then things began to change and suddenly
our club became more popular and we
started to have new members I remembered
I remembered Greek writers and poets
joins first came on board and then
writers from Hungary and Poland and then
interestingly writers from Austria the
Netherlands France and then writers from
the UK where I live and where I called
my home and then writers from the USA
suddenly there were more of us feeling
worried about the fate of our nation's
and the future of the world and maybe
there were more of us now feeling like
strangers in our own motherland and then
this bizarre thing happens those of us
who used to be very depressed for a long
time we started to feel less depressed
whereas the newcomers they were so not
used to feeling this way that they were
now even more depressed so you could you
could see writers from Bangladesh or
Turkey or Egypt trying to console their
colleagues
bricks at Britton or from post-election
USA but joking aside I think our world
is full of unprecedented challenges and
this comes with an emotional backlash
because in the face of high-speed change
many people wish to slow down and when
there's too much unfamiliarity people
long for the familiar and when things
get too confusing
many people crave simplicity this is a
very dangerous crossroads because it's
exactly where the demagogue enters into
the picture the demagogue understands
how collective sentiments work and how
he it's usually a he can't benefit from
them he tells us that we all belong in
our tribes and he tells us that we will
be safer if we're surrounded by sameness
demagogues come in all sizes and in all
shapes this could be the eccentric
leader of a marginal political party
somewhere in Europe or an Islamist
extremist Imam preaching Dogma and
hatred or it could be a white
supremacist Nazi admiring orator
somewhere else all these figures at
first glance they seem disconnected but
I think they feed each other and they
need each other and all around the world
when we look at how demagogues talk and
how the how they inspire movements I
think they have one unmistakable quality
in common they strongly strongly dislike
plurality they cannot deal with
multiplicity
Adorno used to say in tolerance of
ambiguity is the sign of an
authoritarian personality but I ask
myself what if that same sign that same
intolerance of ambiguity what if it's
this if it's the mark of our times of
the age we're living in because wherever
I look I see nuances withering away on
TV shows we have one unties
something speaker situated against the
pro something speaker yeah it's good
ratings it's even better if they shout
at each other even in academia where our
intellect is supposed to be nourished
you see one atheist scholar competing
with a firmly feast scholar but it's not
a real intellectual exchange because
it's a clash between two certainties
I think binary opposition's are are
everywhere so slowly and systematically
we are being denied the right to be
complex Istanbul Berlin is Paris
Brussels Dhaka Baghdad Barcelona we have
seen one horrible terror attack after
another and when you express your sorrow
and when you react against the cruelty
you get all kinds of reactions messages
on social media but one of them is quite
disturbing only because it's so
widespread they say why do you feel
sorry for them why do you feel sorry for
them why don't you feel sorry for
civilians in Yemen or civilians in Syria
and I think the people who write such
messages do not understand that we can't
feel sorry for and stand in solidarity
with victims of terrorism and violence
in the Middle East in Europe in Asia in
America wherever everywhere equally and
simultaneously they don't seem to
understand that we don't have to pick
one pain and one place over over all
others but I think this is what
tribalism does to us it shrinks our
minds for sure but it also shrinks our
hearts to such an extent that we become
numb to the suffering of other people
and the sad truth is we weren't always
like this
I had a children's book out in in Turkey
and when when the book was published I
did lots of events I went to many
primary schools which gave me a chance
to observe younger kids in Turkey and it
was always amazing
to see how much empathy imagination and
hutzpah they have these children are
much more inclined to become global
citizens than nationalists at that age
and it's wonderful to see when you ask
them so many of them want to be poets
and writers and girls are just as
confident as boys if not even more but
then I would go to high schools and
everything has changed now nobody wants
to be a writer anymore now nobody wants
to be a novelist anymore and girls have
become timid they are cautious guarded
reluctant to speak up in the public
space because we have taught them the
family the school the society we have
taught them to erase their individuality
I think east and west we are losing
multiplicity both within our societies
and within ourselves and coming from
Turkey I do know that the loss of
diversity is a major major loss today my
motherland became the world's biggest
jailer for journalists surpassing even
China's sad record and I also believe
that what happened over there in Turkey
can happen anywhere it can even happen
here so just like solid countries was an
illusion singular identities is also an
illusion because we all have a
multiplicity of voices inside the Irani
and the persian poet Hafez he used to
say you carry in your soul every
ingredients necessary to turn your
existence into joy all you have to do is
to mix those ingredients and I think
mixed we can I am an Istanbul light yeah
but I'm also attached to the Balkans the
Aegean the Mediterranean the Middle East
the Levant I am a European by birth by
choice the values that I uphold I have
become a Londoner over the years I would
like to think of myself as a glow
Sol as a world citizen a nomads and an
itinerant storyteller I have multiple
attachments just like all of us and
multiple attachments means multiple
stories as writers we always chase
stories of course but I think we're also
interested in silences the things we
cannot talk about political taboos
cultural taboos we're also interested in
our own silences I have always been very
vocal about and written extensively
about minority rights women's rights
LGBT rights but as I was thinking about
this TED talk I realized one thing I
have never had the courage to say in a
public space that I was bisexual myself
because I so feared the slander and the
stigma and the ridicule and the hatred
that was sure to follow but of course
one should never ever remain silence for
fear of complexity
and although I'm no stranger to
anxieties and although I'm talking here
about the power of emotions I do know
the power of emotions I have discovered
all the time that emotions are not
limitless you know they have a limit
there comes the moment it's like a
tipping point or a threshold when you
get tired of feeling afraid when you get
tired or feeling anxious and I think not
only individuals but perhaps Nations to
have their own tipping points so even
stronger than my emotions is my
awareness that not only gender not only
identity but life itself is fluid they
want to divide us into tribes but we are
connected across borders they preach
certainty but we know that life has
plenty of magic and plenty of ambiguity
and they like to incite dualities but we
are far more nuanced than that so what
can we do I think we need to go back to
the basics back to the colors of the
alphabet the Lebanese poet Khalil Gibran
used to say I learned silence from the
talkative and tolerance from the
intolerant and kindness from the unkind
I think it's a great motto for our times
so from populist demagogues we will
learn the indispensability of democracy
and from isolationists we will learn the
need for global solidarity and from
tribalists we will learn the beauty of
cosmopolitanism and the beauty of
diversity as I finish I want to leave
you with one word or one taste the word
youth in Turkish means motherland's it
means homeland but interestingly the
word also means a tent used by nomadic
tribes and I like that combination
because it makes me think homelands do
not need to be rooted in one place yeah
they can be portable we can take them
with us
everywhere and I think for writers for
story tellers at the end of the day
there is one main homeland and it's
called story land and the taste of that
word is a taste of freedom thank you
[Applause]
[Music]